brought to life after 72 million years
scientists have been able to recreate
this newly discovered species of
dinosaur after finding its fossil in
Patagonia in southern Chile
it's an evolutionary link to duck bills
that have only been found in the
northern hemisphere so to find one here
so far away from all the others of that
type that were known is an important
biogeographical mystery how they managed
to survive here isolated in the south of
the world that's also a story
fossilized bones of the goncocon nanoi
were first discovered 10 years ago
during an expedition by the Chilean
Antarctic Institute researchers dug up
more than 100 fragments which were used
to digitally reconstruct the skeleton
scientists estimated it grew up to four
meters long and weighed around a ton
because it was a herbivorous dinosaur
that could walk on two or four legs one
of the main characteristics is that it
had dozens of teeth forming a sort of
dental battery this allowed them to
process very efficiently the plant food
they fed on it was an animal that lived
in herds it was gregarious
scientists are now planning to make a 3D
print which is due to go on display in
Chile so more people will be able to
appreciate this snapshot of History
Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera